why are you wearing glasses uh um
reading i didn't know you could read
sorry about that you would never guess
that some of the most
iconic moments in the harry potter films
were actually improvised
talk about movie magic when you bring
together so many talented people
like the incredible cast of harry potter
you inevitably get moments that were
never supposed to happen
that's the beauty of adaptations in the
process of translating the book to
screen and bringing what's on screen to
life
actors improvise lines and moments that
end up feeling totally earned and
natural
from onset accidents to memorable lines
these moments
totally had you fooled into thinking
they were planned all along
i know but it's the only plan we've got
at 13 years old daniel radcliffe was
keeping pace with the best of the best
hard to believe but the tense face-off
between harry and lucius malfoy at the
end of chamber of secrets was improvised
after dumbledore dismisses lucius he's
supposed to leave the room without
another word but jason isaacs ad-libbed
the quip
let us hope harry potter is always
around to save the day
but harry claps back don't worry
i will be it's a pitch perfect moment
that was all
daniel radcliffe fitting two in that
harry potter the character and the story
will always be around
all thanks to the wonderfully dedicated
fans
it's not a term one usually hears in
civilized conversation
sometimes actors are so talented you can
just roll the camera and capture the
magic that ensues
that's exactly what director david yates
did for the scene in deathly hallows
part one where bellatrix tortures
hermione he had two phenomenal actresses
in helena bonham carter
and emma watson and letting them do
their thing was definitely the right
choice
as much of the scene was improvised to
top it off the most excruciating detail
when bellatrix carves the word mudblood
onto hermione's arm
was also the actress's idea stop stop
stop
one of our favorite ron and hermione
moments comes early in the series
at the end of chamber of secrets the
trio is reunited after hermione was
petrified by the basilisk
leaving us teary-eyed every time the
script had hermione hug both
harry and ron but emma watson was too
nervous to hug them both so she
improvised the wonderfully awkward
handshake with ron it ends up being a
great moment that says so much about
their relationship
infamous moment when voldemort hugs
malfoy in the deathly hallows was never
in the script
it's such an odd moment for voldemort to
hug malfoy that it could only have been
a spur of the moment choice by the
brilliant ralph finnis
apparently he only did the hug in one of
the takes too but it was so bizarre and
effective that that was the take they
went with for the movie
like all of us watching tom felton
didn't see it coming so his baffled
reaction was totally genuine
dobby feels most aggrieved sir another
great improvised moment is all thanks to
the wonders of technology
jason isaacs started kicking out at thin
air in the scene when lucius leaves
dumbledore's office
to the confusion of chris columbus who
thought he was tripping on something
really he was improvising the moment
when lucius kicks dobby down the stairs
just to add that extra bit of cruelty to
the character
one person couldn't feel all that that
explode
as the trio got older and less innocent
they also started to experience
more tension within the group but they
share a great moment in order of the
phoenix
sitting around the gryffindor common
room discussing harry's love life
hermione explains how cho must be
feeling and quips that rod got the
emotional range of a teaspoon
the laugh that the three share after
emma watson delivers this line was
apparently a genuine laugh from the
actors we're glad they kept it
[Music]
one of the funniest moments in the
movies has to be the moment in chamber
of secrets when malfoy stumbles on ron
and harry who have taken polyjuice
potion to disguise themselves as crab
and goyal
malfoy can't imagine why goyle is
wearing reading glasses and casually
throws out what the naked breed
it's all in tom felton's delivery
apparently he'd forgotten his actual
line and improvised this hilarious bit
of dialogue
harry potter
is dead in deathly hallows part 2
voldemort gives a grand speech during
the battle of hogwarts
to demonstrate his power and compel
those still fighting the good fight to
fall in line
but surprisingly the speech terrifying
in its menace
wasn't totally scripted ralph finn has
improvised much of it
changing up his lines each take to keep
the reactions of those listening
fresh according to jason isaacs it kept
a courtyard of extras and actors on
their toes
we bet it did you've got dirt on your
nose by the way
seeing how young the harry potter cast
was back in the first movie makes us
super nostalgic for more
innocent times the trio's first scene
together was the beginning of it all but
did you know that part of the scene was
improvised by emma watson
when hermione realizes she's talking to
the harry potter
she shouts holy cricket you're harry
potter the holy cricket exclamation was
totally improvised
director chris columbus loved it and
kept it in how do i look
exceptionally ordinary dancing is hard
and it's easy to make a fool of yourself
doing it but luna lovegood
is one person who dances like no one's
watching in the deathly hallows part 1
luna's hilariously odd dance with her
father at bill and fleur's wedding
wasn't scripted
ivana lynch wanted to create a luna
worthy dance to perform for the scene
and what she came up with was so strange
and amazing that we can't imagine the
scene without it
master has given dobby a shock
what i didn't in the script for chamber
of secrets
lucius tries to cast some minor curse on
harry after he helps to free dobby
jason isaacs apparently forgot what
curse he was supposed to say
and said the first thing that came to
mind which happened to be avada kadavra
we'd say going straight to the killing
curse is a bit of an overreaction
thankfully dobby intervenes before he
can finish it the moment works because
it shows how unstable and frightening
lucius can be
you shall not harm harry potter
who could forget mr weasley's super
serious question to harry in chamber of
secrets
tell me what exactly is the function of
a rubber duck
this moment was also improvised mark
williams who played arthur weasley came
up with a whole series of funny
muggle-related questions to ask harry in
the scene where they first met
he would change it up each take for
maximum comedic impact
if only we could have been a fly on the
wall while they were filming this scene
there's no hogus without you hagrid at
the end of chamber of secrets
after hagrid has been vindicated he gets
a standing ovation from all of hogwarts
well almost everyone but malfoy and his
crew
naturally but crab apparently didn't get
the memo he stands and claps along with
everyone else before malfoy yanks him
back down
but this moment wasn't supposed to
happen apparently the actor who plays
crab
didn't realize what was going on and
stood to clap by accident
chris columbus liked it and decided to
make it part of the scene
the climax of the order of the phoenix
is a tense standoff between dumbledore's
army and the death eaters inside the
ministry of magic
harry's friends are fascinated with
death eaters including the sadistic
bellatrix lestrange
who has neville at wand point helena
bottom carter got a little too
into character though apparently bonham
carter jammed her wand into matthew
lewis's ear by accident
but since it was very in character they
left it in the only
issue is she actually perforated lewis
eardrum
ouch don't play with wands kids
lucius malfoy swoops into the chamber of
secrets with flowing blonde locks
dark wardrobe and iconic slytherin cane
and suddenly
it totally clicks why draco is the way
he is but lucius was originally
described much differently he's so fully
realized by jason isaacs that you would
never suspect it but it's true
isaac's put his own stamp on the
character and designed the whole look
from platinum blonde head to toe
the wand in the cane was also his idea
we're ready for you now follow me the
scene when the first years enter the
great hall for the first time
and finally see it in all its majesty
was actually the first time that the
actors stepped foot on the great hall
set
so their odd reactions are totally real
of course the floating
candles and magical ceiling were special
effects but it's still a remarkable set
and having the kids react off the cuff
makes the moment that much more magical
[Music]
barty crouch jr is maybe the creepiest
character in the whole series
and that's all thanks to david tennant's
deliciously slimy performance
his snake-like tick of flicking his
tongue only reinforced how much of a
duplicitous death eater he was
interestingly the constant tongue
flicking was improvised by david tennant
it's one of those rare improvisations
that ends up being crucial to the plot
since the characteristic flickering
tongue is a dead giveaway that mad i
moody is not who he seems
you won because i made it so potter
finally in prisoner of azkaban director
alfonso curon
wanted to add a touch of realism to the
characters who were always in uniform in
the previous two films so he asked
everyone playing hogwarts students to
wear their uniforms however they liked
that's why you'll notice some students
looking very put together
and others looking disheveled with
crooked ties and untucked shirts
it's that kind of attention to detail
that makes the harry potter movies feel
so real
despite the magic all right then i'll
use my torch to you're right
sorry i know it's hard one of the best
parts of a blockbuster movie or a hit tv
series
is the behind the scenes bloopers that
have fans laughing until they cry
but what about the bloopers that
actually make it into the final cut
welcome back the things fans have you
ever thought you caught a glimpse of an
actor laughing in a super serious scene
or caught a moment on screen that looked
a little too real to be acting
actors jobs are to bring characters to
life and make them seem like real people
well the truth is that a lot of the time
actors do this by being real
or themselves in this video we'll be
taking you through some of the most
shocking unscripted on-screen moments
with actors like millie bobby brown
tom holland and hollywood legend robin
williams himself
buckle up this could get real
the stranger things cast may be at the
beginning of their careers but they give
their all into every performance
in this season 3 scene when 11 is
fighting a possessed billy
she's so tired that she falls back into
michael but we discovered that millie
bobby brown
actually broke character in this scene
and is the one who fell back into finn
this scene was so intense that even she
was exhausted
if you look closely you can see finn
glancing at the directors and concern
because he totally wasn't expecting it
a creepy killer clown is bad enough
through a screen imagine seeing one in
real life
that's exactly what happened to the cast
of the horror movie it
the child actors that made up the losers
club were kept separate from bill
skarsgard when he was in his full
pennywise makeup and costume
i think we all also decided mutually
that it would be good to see him for the
first time and
just be freaked out the first time they
saw him altogether was when they were
filming the infamous projector scene
the fear on their faces is completely
real
it wasn't friends at first sight for
this superhero duo
in fact it took quite a while for tony
stark to warm up to peter parker
that's why this car scene between the
two was nothing but awkward and it's all
thanks to tom holland breaking character
it's not a hug i'm just grabbing the
door for you we're not we're not there
yet
the hug between them was actually tom
holland trying to be funny
and robert downey jr's line afterward
about opening the car door
is him trying to save the scene improv
just works for these two
in avengers infinity war tom holland
also improvised his death scene with
robert downey jr
i don't want to go you don't want to go
start please
his line was completely unscripted and
made not only the characters but the
actor's emotions more real
the filming for this scene took a
dangerous turn there's a reason why isla
fisher's character henley looks like
she's really drowning during one of her
illusion tricks
aila did all of her stunts for this
movie so during the filming
she was actually drowning luckily
nothing went terribly wrong and we got
the awesome scene that ended up in the
final cut
would you ever take on a role in a
horror series even if we told you that
some directors purposely scare
actors on camera to get a genuine
reaction this exact thing happened
during a scene for the hit netflix show
the haunting of hill house actress
victoria pedretti as nell pops her head
out from the back seat of a car in order
to scare her two sisters but during one
take she did it earlier than expected
the reactions from the actresses kate
siegel and elizabeth reiser are
completely real
do you remember kevin's electric
performance of tear me down in
riverdale's season 4 musical episode
well kevin's actor casey cott and kj
appa teamed up to shock the other actors
in one scene kevin kisses archie it was
totally unscripted
and makes the look of shock on everyone
else's faces even more priceless
kj appa was putting so much effort into
this scene that he actually broke his
hand
during the emotional season one episode
where archie rescues cheryl from the
lake where she's trapped under ice
he punches away with it with his bare
hands while kj was of course punching a
mat over the ice
he still managed to break his hand while
filming the scene
bird box broke records at netflix and
with how much work went into the film
we're not surprised one shocking fact
about the film is that sandra bullock
really was blindfolded during her scenes
and
actually couldn't see that means mallory
stumbling around on the scene wasn't all
acting
it was very real the joker film was
nothing short of spectacular
and a lot of it is thanks to joaquin
phoenix there's actually an iconic scene
included in the movie that was all
thanks to joakim's emotions and not
acting at all
one day on set he got to hear the
soundtrack to the film for the first
time
his lone tear in this scene is actually
his reaction to hearing the music
lara jean and peter k's love story is
probably one we've all dreamt of once in
our lives but
how much of it was lara and peter and
how much of it was their actors
lana and noah having fun if you pay
attention to the film
lara jean's lock screen is actually her
and peter napping
but according to the director the photo
on her phone was actually taken
of lana and noah napping together in
between takes
any kid would be scared of maleficent
we're even scared of maleficent
that's why for the film the only child
who would work as toddler aurora was
angelina jolie's daughter vivian
the acting in their adorable scenes
together is really just vivian trying to
get her mother's attention
malfoy and crab had a reputation to
uphold at hogwarts so when we see malfoy
stop his friend from clapping after a
gryffindor victory
we think nothing of it but the scene is
actually tom felton
stopping his co-star from clapping
because he knew he wasn't supposed to
tom was really trying to keep cool calm
and collected here
grey's anatomy has been around for years
so the actors have gotten pretty good at
their jobs
but of course they still break character
every now and again
in this scene jessica capshaw decided to
improv a kiss between her
and camilla luddington the shock on
joe's face is 100
camilla michael scott's last episode of
the office was extremely emotional for
the characters but it was also hard for
the actors to say goodbye to steve
carell
that's why in the scene where pam rushes
to the airport to say goodbye to michael
the emotional performance by jenna
fisher wasn't a performance
at all if you ever watch supernatural
you know that dean's famous catchphrase
is
well there was one time when jensen
ackles decided to add the line in when
it wasn't scripted
but he said it with a little too much
enthusiasm jared padalecki was
not expecting it and burst out laughing
the director loved it
and decided to keep the take
jason segel had no idea that his
character marshall would be losing his
father in the series
in fact the first time he found out was
when alison hannigan's character told
him
the emotion on his face is actually his
reaction to finding out the news
david schwimmer managed to pull off a
practical joke on jennifer aniston while
filming friends
and it was used in an episode he along
with his sidekick cole sprouse pretended
like he had fallen down the stairs
but it was really only a dummy that fell
jennifer had no idea it was going to
happen so rachel's panic and screams in
the scene were really jennifer freaking
out
robin williams was of course a comedic
genius in goodwill hunting during a
therapy scene with matt damon
he tells him a hilarious story about the
flatulence problem his character's wife
had
the story was so funny because it was
completely made up by robin
matt damon's smiles and laughs are all
real pretty woman
is a hollywood classic and millennials
today still strive to have the aesthetic
julia roberts brought to that screen
we're here to tell you that one of the
most iconic scenes was
in fact completely unscripted when julia
roberts gets her hand caught in the
jewelry box that richard gere closes
her reaction wasn't acting she had no
idea that he was going to do that at all
are you okay
how many times have you bawled your eyes
out at a super sad moment on screen
we hear you and we've been there too but
it's not just us
discover the scenes in movies like harry
potter and tv shows like friends where
the cast got just as choked up as the
audience get the kleenex ready
i teared up a little bit watching sophie
in that scene
filming a scene where your on-screen
twin passes away sure
sounds tough and for oliver phelps it
was very emotional
he asked director david yates and
co-star julie walters how to get into
that mindset
and he revealed he ended up thinking
about loved ones i've lost over the
years a makeup artist then came over
with eucalyptus spray and blew in his
eyes he admitted i'm crying for real at
that point they did it in just two takes
james phelps wasn't affected at all by
the crying he had to lie there for so
long
he actually fell asleep and woke up on
my own on the stage while everyone went
to lunch
will smith's raw performance and the
pursuit of happiness gave us serious
goosebumps and the emotion in the final
scene got to will himself too
he cried real tears and it's hardly
surprising the actor revealed how
important it was for him to do justice
to the true story it was based on
he connected with chris gardner the real
man he was portraying on screen so that
he could tell his story
and working with his own son jaden when
he was just eight years old
also made it a mega emotional experience
for will
was it as easy as it looked no sir
i'm sorry it wasn't riverdale paid
tribute to the late luke perry
following his fatal stroke with its
season four premiere the episode
featured fred andrews's funeral the
character that luke portrayed in the
show
given the real life events it's not
surprising that the cast were crying
real tears of grief and loss as they
mourned their former co-star
it was an immensely moving moment for
all of us watching at home as well and a
beautiful way to pay tribute
we're honoring him the best we could it
was the best way yeah
the ending of captain phillips wasn't in
the original script
it was entirely improvised and that
makes tom hanks's raw performance
all the more affecting he let the
emotion of the scene wash over him
the actor revealed that it was
instinctual and he couldn't really
remember it afterwards as he was just so
physically engrossed in the procedure
that was happening to him
he had spoken to the real person he was
portraying beforehand and tom had
discovered that phillips couldn't stop
crying
a navy seal had told him not to fight it
and let it flow out of his system
and that's exactly what tom did
everything's gonna be okay denzel
washington shows so much
in such a small physical moment when he
lets a tear fall down his cheek as he's
flogged in glory
his back already bears the scars of his
punishment as a runaway slave
it's an incredibly moving moment and
highlights the power of the actor
the cast of glee paid tribute to cory
monteith after his tragic passing with a
beautifully touching episode titled the
quarterback the actor's tears were
of course real as the cast let their raw
emotion show
while acting their characters mourning
the passing of finn leah michelle
was in a real relationship with corey at
the time of his passing and her genuine
tears as she sang adele's make you feel
my love
moved us all to tears too come on let's
hang it right over there
when 11 reads an emotional letter left
for her by police chief hopper in the
final episode her tears are seriously
convincing
and that's because millie bobby brown
was genuinely crying the actor has
discussed how she got herself into the
zone to deliver the emotional scenes in
stranger things third
season she listened to the recording
from her co-star david harbour and got
the camera on her straight away
to capture her raw reaction which she
describes as pure devastation and
sadness
and when life hurts you because it will
remember the hurt finishing up a
franchise of films
is going to be emotional and that's
exactly how daisy ridley felt when her
role as rey in the star wars series
came to a full stop she was so upset
about the end of the line that she
didn't need to pretend to cry in her
emotional scenes
those tears flowed naturally in an
interview she revealed
in the shot i'm just crying in the shot
it was it was
incredibly dramatic she literally
couldn't remember what she said
afterwards she just hugged the cast and
crew and left in a car
staring out of the window saying goodbye
to their sitcom of 10 years was a very
emotional moment for the cast of friends
so they didn't have to put on the tears
in their final scene
courtney cox starts crying and she sets
off jennifer aniston
and david schwimmer lisa kudrow and matt
leblanc also shed a tear the only one
who didn't
matthew perry he kept it together but
admitted he felt like he was going to
cry throughout the seven
hours of their last day this is harder
than i thought it would be
benedict cumberbatch cared so deeply for
the character he played in the imitation
game that he genuinely cried
in fact on the last day of shooting he
was so moved he couldn't stop the tears
from flowing the actor revealed that
while filming the final scene
he broke down and couldn't control
himself and i couldn't stop crying
he said he grieved for the beautiful and
brilliant man
during an interview with jimmy kimmel
jennifer lawrence revealed what caused
sophie turner to cry real tears in an
emotional scene
it's the moment when her god-like powers
cause her to accidentally end
jennifer's character's life and it's all
because her vape got taken away as jen
revealed
she really was crying because her
dialect coach right before the take took
her
jewel away sophie joined the joking by
saying it's
how to act take it away and then you
give it back
scream is terrifying to watch but was it
terrifying to make well drew barrymore
wanted to cry real tears
so she made an agreement with wes craven
about how to approach the crying scenes
wes would tell her a secret story and it
brought the tears on
every time wes revealed what their
secret was about it was a story drew had
told him about a boy who had done awful
things to his dog so the director just
had to say one line to the actor and
she'd burst into tears
and be just frantic
[Music]
drew barrymore has a history of really
crying in her movies
way back when she was little she played
gertie in et
and she was able to give a very raw
genuine performance because the cast and
crew
encouraged her to believe the
extraterrestrial was actually real in a
behind
scenes featurette her co-star henry
thomas who played elliott
revealed that drew introduced e.t to her
mom and said
he doesn't want to talk to you right now
but he's just a little shy
her co-star robert mcnaughton said it
must have been very upsetting for her
when she had to say goodbye to e.t
jessica elba's crying scene in fantastic
four rise of the silver surfer
is fascinating for a different reason
she revealed that making the movie
actually made her want to stop acting
and that's all down to director tim
story's response to her genuine crying
she revealed that the director said her
crying looked too real
and too painful well duh that's how it's
supposed to be
but then get this he added can you be
prettier when you cry
cry pretty jessica just wow he wanted
her to make her face
flat so they could then cgi the tears in
as jessica quite rightly pointed out
then there's no connection to a human
being
hey would you feel knowing some of the
steamiest on-screen kisses you've seen
were real
because they weren't meant to happen in
the first place these actors found
themselves in spontaneous
steamy and occasionally hilarious
moments with kisses that were never
written into the script whether it was a
crush
a direction or in the moment move these
smooches are unforgettable and made for
some great stories
let's take a look at these 20 kisses
that were totally improvised
i want you to watch this and i want you
to burn this into your brains
in the finale of season two max and
lucas share a sweet kiss at the snowball
dance
this kiss was never written in and later
in an episode of beyond stranger things
actress sadie sink confessed that she
wasn't comfortable with the scene
earlier in the day she was told that
there would be a kiss and she protested
what no
no that's not in the script that's not
happening the actress unfortunately felt
like she didn't have a choice
so she wound up doing the kiss on camera
while filming jurassic world chris pratt
and bryce dallas howard share a kiss
after she saves him from a small
dinosaur and helps him up from the
ground
turns out this wasn't scripted and
director colin trevorrow had pulled
pratt aside right before they filmed the
scene to tell him to surprise his
co-star with a kiss
and i was like ah hollywood the 2015
film the hunger games mockingjay part 2
included a smooch between woody
harrelson and elizabeth banks that
harrelson initiated
however the kiss wasn't just for the
scene after the fact
harrelson confessed to having a crush on
banks and explained that he'd
spontaneously decided to kiss her
the actor said she's such a pro you know
and went with it while filming
the movie brought a very unexpected kiss
between lawrence and adams during a
tense scene
the kiss wasn't originally meant to
happen but adams thought it would add
something unique to the scene so she
brought the proposal to lawrence before
they filmed
the actresses agreed and now the two
have their moment captured on film
forever
you know it and i know it these two
actors didn't share just one
but multiple unplanned kisses over the
seven seasons of the series
it was max greenfield playing schmidt
that initiated
all the unplanned smooches with his
co-star during the first season
as a result it became an ongoing joke
between greenfield and johnson both on
set
and offset they definitely got a lot of
kisses in
as johnson has said that he's locked
lips with greenfield more than
any girl he's ever dated i felt like you
needed that more than i did
the always hilarious steve carell
surprised both viewers and his cast when
he planted a kiss on oscar nunez
it was episode one of season three the
corral decided to lovingly smooch nunes
character in front of everyone to make
up for some homophobic comments he'd
made
the whole scene was actually improvised
by corel
there were versions of the scene that
were filmed without the kiss but we are
glad they included this take in the
episode
episode 24 of season 14 of the medical
drama brought a spontaneous and silly
kiss to the screen
ludington who plays joe goofy kissed
capshaw's character
arizona the kiss came between two pecks
to joe's fiancee alex
it caught everyone by surprise and
ludington explained that while doing the
exciting and joyous scene
she thought who wouldn't want to kiss
arizona robbins
i was the biggest fan i'd watched since
the beginning while filming a romantic
scene on the beach
the director of the 2010 film started
telling cyrus and hemsworth to try doing
different things for the scene
like splashing and pushing each other
then she said they should kiss
and they did well your sister just got
kissed
dad that wasn't the last time they
locked lips since after that the actors
dated for eight years and were married
for another two
episode 17 of the fourth season was a
special musical episode tribute to the
cult classic
hedwig and the angry inch what's up
riverdale are you trying to tear me down
actor casey cott was singing a song from
the show that traditionally includes
kissing a random audience member while
filming the scene
kot opted to do the same and picked
fellow actor kj app for the surprise
kiss
in a flirtatious scene from the second
episode of season seven
there was a surprise kiss between gemma
whelan and indira varma
it seems like you don't need a protector
wheelen later said that it wasn't in the
script however
while the two were acting together it
felt like they should do the kiss
the 2011 supernatural drama series
brought viewers a sweet and spontaneous
kiss on the cheek
given to rhoden by o'brien in the
premiere of season six
turns out it was a great move because
fans were so excited by the idea of them
being together that it resulted in a
romantic storyline for the characters in
the series
hey lydia thank goodness because we are
absolutely team stydia one of the most
noteworthy scenes in a room with a view
was actually made up on the spot
the crew of the film was trying to find
a magical spot for the scene to take
place
wanting corn flowers originally they
ended up having to settle for a poppy
field
the actors were given some loose
guidelines juden you stand there
and then the romantic kiss came along
naturally how could it not in an italian
poppy field
the writers of the 2014 sci-fi film had
a hard time finding where a romantic
moment could happen between blunt and
cruz's characters
so blunt went ahead and took it into her
own hands that's a challenge
after the writers gave up on trying to
write the kiss in blunt went ahead
and kissed cruz we think tom cruise was
probably pretty happy about the surprise
the two actors were reunited in this
film after not appearing on screen
together for nearly 35 years
look one of the most
tender and heart-wrenching scenes of the
film has a kiss that was totally
spontaneous
it came pretty easily since the two
actors had such a long history
shortly after filming fisher passed away
we imagine hamill was happy to have that
special moment with her
the 2003 film has a long kiss between
the co-stars after murray whispers in
johansen's ear in the final scene
everything from the whisper to the kiss
was made up on the spot by murray
what was whispered remained a secret for
years
while filming the graduation scene
garfield and stone shared a spontaneous
kiss
the kiss was pretty in the moment and
natural since the two were dating at the
time
garfield said that while they were
shooting the scene he figured his
character would kiss stone at that
moment
and since they were locking lips
regularly he probably didn't give it
much more thought
can't keep me away tommy davidson
thought it would bring some excitement
to the film if he kissed pinkett smith
on set while filming one of the scenes
it wasn't the best surprise because
davidson didn't realize that a kiss
should be rehearsed and agreed upon when
he moved in to kiss his co-star
she pulled back and they didn't end up
fully kissing will smith was
very upset about the incident and nearly
fought davidson over the unexpected pass
so i was like all right let's go outside
let's talk and then jada was like no
no no y'all in a scene where mcgillis
character
passionately tells cruz's character i
just don't want anyone to know that i've
fallen
cruz responds with a kiss this was
unplanned
and the only reason it happened was
because crews forgot his lines and
decided to kiss her instead
episode 5 of season 5 has a scene that
includes a kiss between jacks
played by hunnam and venus van damme a
transgendered prostitute played by
goggins
the kiss wasn't scripted goggins
whispered to hanum
just trust me before shooting the scene
and after they called action
goggins gave hunnum the tender kiss
goodbye
tag
the finale of season one brought a
surprise kiss between fellow teachers
will and
emma i love you emma i finally said it
well
the truth is it was only a shock for one
of them
writer director brad falchuk told
morrison to surprise mays with a smooch
before they filmed the scene
making mazes reaction totally authentic
sup guys wait a minute you guys aren't
the real avengers
sometimes unscripted moments breathe
more life into a scene
the adults are talking and other times
they i'm so sorry
fall short luckily in the mcu the
improvisation gene is impeccably strong
amongst its actors
so in this video we're taking you
through all of spider-man's unscripted
moments that completely took the films
to another level
action we all know tony stark isn't one
to get himself caught up in emotional
moments
and in spider-man homecoming peter
parker learned that in a pretty awkward
way
after tony stark has a talk with peter
in his car he reaches over to open the
car door
but peter thinks he's actually leaning
in for a hug remember
that's not a hug i'm just grabbing the
door for you well check out what tom
holland had to say about the scene
well that was actually an improvised
moment i think i just tried to hug him i
just thought it would be funny if i
hugged him
the hilarious moment was completely
improvised for laughs but robert downey
jr went along with it
speaking about tony stark and his
emotions during the final moments of
avengers infinity war
he was nothing but emotional same mr
stark
as spider-man turned into nothingness in
his arms we were all a puddle of tears
when he desperately chants
i don't want to go you don't want to go
start please
oh you didn't want to go that was all
tom holland again
the director gave him free reign on the
death scene and tom
delivered even if he doesn't think it
was that spectacular himself
i don't want to go three times in a row
so it's not that amazing of an ad-lib
it's hard to believe spider-man is one
of tom's first big roles
tom holland and zendaya's chemistry is
off the charts
peter parker and mj are like magic on
screen together
and a lot of that is thanks to the
actor's off-screen friendship
according to zendaya tom has a habit of
deviating from the script
but thankfully they're so in tune with
one another that she was able to respond
right back
no matter how annoyed she was it just
kept
improving he just did not stick to the
script he was trying to throw me off
what's your favorite peter in mj scene
she knows i told her
he didn't tell me i figured it out if
there's one thing better than watching
peter and mj on screen
it's watching peter mj and ned interact
with one another
but the truth is a lot of the time we're
watching their off-screen relationships
shine through the camera remember in
spider-man far from home
ned walks in on mj and peter while he's
changing into his spider-man suit
the costume looks great for the costume
party
well ned wasn't in on the fact that mj
had found out their secret
and tried to play it off ned's actor
jacob batalon
actually said that was one of his
favorite scenes to shoot because he got
to improv all his comments
there was a lot of laughter on set that
day we have to give jake gyllenhaal
credit for playing such a convincing
role as mysterio
who knew that he would actually turn out
as a villain in the end but it looks
like we should be praising jake for more
than just his impeccable acting skills
according to the actor he and director
john watts came up with a lot of
unscripted moments for his character
that ended up in the film we don't know
what specific scenes these moments are
in but let's just appreciate mysterio
for a sec
somebody get this stupid costume off me
having at may be played by a younger
actress in the marvel universe gave us a
whole other perspective on her
relationship with peter
it's so comforting to see the two of
them interact on screen
but you'll be shocked to find out that a
lot of their scenes were unscripted as
well
one specific improvised moment in
spider-man homecoming happened while
they're eating in the thai restaurant
how many times you have to say larb
before
you talk to me you know i love you their
conversation was just something the
actor made up on the fly with some
guidance from the director
yet again we have another improvised
moment between peter parker
and tony stark this time it's in captain
america's civil war
check it out i'm gonna sit here so you
move the leg
tony stark telling peter to move over
might seem like it was in character and
it is
but it was also robert downey jr's way
of telling tom holland to scoot over
onto his set marker without ruining the
entire take
funnily enough it ended up in the final
cut can you even
see in these yes yes i can't look i
can't
samuel l jackson got his moment to shine
in spider-man as his character nick fury
he even got sassy with spider-man
although the line wasn't even scripted
when peter admits he's a little hesitant
to join their newest plan
fury says please you've been to space
samuel l jackson may not have recalled
whether the line was improvised but jake
gyllenhaal jumped in to confirm it was
100
unscripted i'm here to attest that was
improvised
despite his hesitancy with nick fury
peter was all in for helping out iron
man on his avengers infinity war mission
but tony stark wasn't having it or
should we say robert downey jr wasn't
having it
while iron man is having a discussion
with doctor strange peter chimes in that
he's back up
i'm back up no you're still away the
adults are talking but that was yet
again another improvised line between
the unscripted heroes tom holland and
robert downey jr
spider-man far from home is full of
european landmarks that make the entire
movie stunning
even if a lot of them do get destroyed
according to a screen rant interviewer
a lot of improvising happened in a
specific landmark the london tower
the film's final battle takes place in
london and supposedly during this scene
the cast shot so many versions because
of their ability to improvise
you'd never be able to tell in the final
cut they joined forces like the power
rangers
you're thinking of voltron voltron you
think you're voltron
drax's line i'll do you one better why
is gamora
is one of the funniest highlights that
came out of avengers infinity war
even if spider-man's life was literally
being threatened in the scene
the line however was actually ad-libbed
by drax's actor dave bautista
the rest of the actors including tom
holland are just so professional that
they rolled with it the camera operator
even seemed to be quick to react
michael keaton got some time to shine in
spider-man homecoming but one of his
best lines
didn't make the final cut according to
tom holland keaton
actually made a direct reference to his
role as batman in the 80s
his character vulture is a little
confused as to why spider-man would save
him
and after tom holland delivers his
because i'm spider-man
keaton supposedly responded but i'm
batman
we don't know if the line was part of
the script but tom holland seemed to be
hinting it was ad-libbed like we
mentioned before
jake gyllenhaal played the perfect
mysterio and a lot of why his character
is so epic may be because of how well he
got along with tom holland
according to tom mysterio and spider-man
were actually meant to bump heads a lot
however while filming their interactions
turned out to be more friendly
the directors decided to let them head
off the script and build their own
relationship between the characters
they basically became bffs good luck kid
i'll give you about a 50 50 chance
you're pretty awkward
so we also see spidey's actual bff ned
get his own romantic interest
but according to ned's actor jacob
batalon ned's relationship with betty
was basically developed by him and
actress and gory rice
he says they were given a lot of space
for improv they may not have lasted
super long as a couple but there's no
doubt they were adorable
i would totally kiss you but i think i
just threw up in my mouth a little
i i might have a mint it seems like
jacob batalon had a lot to do with all
his characters relationships with the
chemistry between peter and ned
we've never doubted the way they were
childhood best friends and the chemistry
between the actors off screen
is why it's so authentic apparently
because tom and jacob weren't given the
script days in advance
they never knew their lines which means
their interactions are purely the two
actors playing off one another
do you know him too yeah we met the
difference between success
if we needed any more proof that tom
holland is holding his own when it comes
to the rest of the marvel cast
this video is it watching these actors
not only play superheroes but
be superheroes when it comes to bringing
to life a character
is nothing short of impressive let us
know if you have any other unscripted
spider-man moments we should discuss
thanks for watching the things fans